- [Voiceover] The first
table above shows the number
of premium members at two
premium video rental stores.
A number of premium members
and then this is store A and store B.
During the years two
thousand to two thousand two
the second table shows the average,
arithmetic mean, number of video rentals
per premium member at store
B during each of those years.
Based on this information,
which of the following
best approximates the total
number of video rentals
by, let me underline this,
the total number of video rentals
by premium members at store B
during the years two
thousand to two thousand two?
So, we wanna concern
ourselves with store B
between two thousand and
two thousand and two.
So, let's think about it a little bit.
In the year two thousand
how many total rentals
would there have been?
Well, in the year two thousand you
have five hundred premium members,
you have five hundred premium members
and on average they each rented twelve,
twelve rentals per year,
so, the total number of
rentals per premium member
is going to be five hundred
times five hundred times twelve
and you might be saying,
"Hey, Sal, look, not all of
them rented exactly twelve."
But you have to realize this
average is actually created
by taking the sum of all
the five hundred's rentals
and then dividing by five hundred.
So, if you multiplied
by five hundred again
then you're going to get the
total number that were rented.
Let me just, let me just, let me just,
let me just clarify that for you.
So, if you took, if you knew
the total that were rented,
total rented in two thousand,
well, if you divided that by five hundred,
if you divided that by five hundred,
then you're going to get the average,
you're going to get the average
that were rented per or
the average videos rented
per premium member.
So, then if you multiply both
sides of this by five hundred,
by five hundred, you're going
to get that the total rented
is twelve times five hundred.
And you could view it as on average
twelve videos were rented per member
times five hundred members
and that's exactly what
we did right over there.
Let me clear this up.
And so let me clear that up.
So, now we can think about
the year two thousand and one.
So, in two thousand, two thousand and one,
and it's the same logic.
You have a thousand premium members
and they each rented on
average fifteen videos each.
So, it's going to be one
thousand times fifteen
and then finally in two thousand and two,
two thousand and two you have one thousand
two hundred and fifty premium members
and they each rented twenty videos each
or on average, twenty each.
So, if you sum these up
what're you going to get?
Let's see, five hundred times twelve.
Five times twelve is sixty.
Sixty, and then you have two more zeros.
So, that's six thousand.
One thousand times fifteen
is fifteen thousand
and then, let's see,
one thousand two hundred
and fifty times two would
be twenty five hundred
but then you have another zero
so it's twenty five thousand,
twenty five thousand, you
add these all together
and what do you get?
Six thousand plus fifteen thousand is
twenty one thousand plus
twenty five thousand
is equal to forty six, forty six thousand
which is choice B.
Choice B right over there.